on va faire une interview tir aux
pigeons
allons-y alors facile pour commencer
françois hollande
l'incapable du mieux oui c'est pas mal
nicolas sarkozy le très capable du pire
marine le pen notre copine marine le pen
la honte des enfants de vedettes assez
bon la honte des fix ii voilà
je suis désolé frédéric beigbeder mais
ça va recommencer recouche
parcours d'un collabo à saint germain
des prés voilà après tu commencé comme
ça de la cac le mec pendant la guerre il
l'aurait dénoncé anne franck tu vois
mais après l'avoir niké kom faut dire
comme la décharge de frédéric que ce
grand parents ont caché des juifs un
travail oui m'enfin c'est pas
héréditaire le kunar
eric naulleau la bave du crapaud te
houle la laurence ferrari laurence
ferrari le charme torride de la
bourgeoisie de province
auront été
le bon camarade moins long ces propos ce
que je travaille avec lui tu sais bien
ils me payent pas c'est là où catherine
barma et forte jusque là c'est c'est
très rare de rencontrer quelqu'un
d'aussi solides aussi fiable si droit
dans ce milieu doria tillier la miss
météo de canal
soit belle et ouvre la
dynamique si la ja il faut pas me
chercher
je dirais l'amputer du beau du chic et
du fin mais je ne me moque jamais des
handicapés
alessandra sublet
alexandra sublet il y avait un petit
malaise un derrière l'argent on sent que
ça cartonne quand même hanouna vous avez
dit alessandra sublet l'éclat de rire
qui pardonne tout oui sophia aram
l'absence de rire qui ne pardonne pas
merci car en avant de passer à nos
autres invités je voudrais vous faire
une interview tir aux pigeons mais un
tir aux pigeons cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous appréciez
le plus c'est jean françois copé son
orgue bon tant pis
qu'est ce que vous appréciez chez pierre
gattaz
le fait qu'il me fasse apprécié laurence
parisot finale
crise a précisé
nicolas sarkozy de son absence
il est bon
chez crise apprécié chez frédéric
beigbeder lui lui lui le magazine ah
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous appréciez chez manuel
valls
j'apprécie le fait qu'il y ait 12000
régularisation de sans-papiers en plus
en 2013 ça vous plaît ça ouais qu'est ce
que vous appréciez chez enora malagré
c'est une interview en anglais
et gagna question qu'est ce que vous
appréciez chez vous mes amis j'ai
beaucoup d'amis plus que certains ne le
pensent a
alors christophe j'aimerais maintenant
qu'on profite de vos lumières sur le
monde footballistique
et qu'on fasse une interview tir aux
pigeons
[Musique]
karim benzema
écoutez j'ai été très dur avec lui s'il
est condamné s'il est condamné je pense
qu'il faudrait être dur avec lui dans la
sanction pour l'instant pour l'instant
on peut pas se faire une opinion et
condamner quelqu'un c'est son métier
c'est sa vie le foot l'empêcher de faire
un championnat d'europe seulement pour
des choses qui sont sortis dans la
presse didier deschamps et peut faire
gagner la france à l'euro deschamps il
peut faire gagner tout le monde aille
peut même vous faire gagner l'eurovision
didier deschamps
l'a
vécu il véhicule une chance autour de
lui c'est donc voilà il peut tous nous
faire gagner il est comme pas dakhla
qu'il arrive à parler sans bouger les
lèvres
hatem ben arfa alors voilà qu'à un
gâchis quand même non c'est incroyable
il ya une époque du gâchis c'était moi
je crois que là je crois que là du
hachis c'est mieux maintenant c'est
alors qu'ils ont et qui devrait
aujourd'hui les à nice il fait les
bonnes heures de glisse il devrait être
au barça il devrait être au real madrid
devrait être le plus le plus grand
joueur français malheureusement il ne
l'est pas 27 ans est pas encore trop
tard mais les plus près de la fin que du
début alors vincent labrune est ce que
c'est pas le finalement le pire
directeur de club qu'est l'om
je ne le connais pas je n'en sais rien
voilà tout n'est pas réussi à marseille
c'est compliqué c'est un club tellement
compliqué est ce qu'il y a un président
ou un dirigeant qui a réussi à marseille
saint sernin tapis quand même temps oui
à l'époque mais honnêtement
serge aurier
c'est je comprends pas il vient de dire
dugarry la grosse [ __ ] voilà
sur twitter bon lionel messi aime à dire
c'est le meilleur joueur de tous les
temps de tous les temps ouais
ouais ça nous pousse à vous de tous les
temps
[Rires]
zidane c'est votre copain je vous
demande pas est-ce qu'il va y arriver à
l'effectif je le souhaite mais après
c'est une et club compliqué mais je
pense qu'il vaut mais entraîner le real
madrid même pour une première expérience
que sochaux club oui le meilleur joueur
du monde est un peu plus simple alors
samir nasri
la génération je m'excuse il s'est
excusé il s'est excusé je me souviens je
crois que c'était alors au dernier rôle
s'est excusé et trois jours a pris la
relève mais c'est ça alors on termine
avec christophe dugarry vous en pensez
quoi de christophe dugarry
gens pensent pas grand chose en
défigurant moi j'aime bien non mais je
suis heureux je suis heureux dans ma vie
et puis voilà les choses ça va vous avez
là en tous les cas merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu